venture capitalists money
do vcs help or hurt a business
in general so like in those early stages
in the chase of developing a v1 just
what's the
constructive and destructive
power of money
in the development of a berlin idea
and the deployment of brilliant idea
i have seen brilliant venture
capitalists i have seen horrible ones
ones that care about their lps more than
they care about the entrepreneurs
of course everyone's in it you know at
the end of day especially venture
capital they have to give a return to
their their limited partners the people
who invest in money that they you know
that they have to shepherd that money
and make sure it's watched over properly
but when there's not a balance a push
back in a venture capitals between what
the lp needs and what the entrepreneur
needs
and that the entrepreneur might be
trying really hard but if they don't see
the vc doesn't see the exit's going to
happen in two years and then just leave
them hanging when it's there's no the
value exchange is only money and not
mentorship or ideas or other things
when there's not a relationship but
really a transaction
that's when money is toxic
because you can get money everywhere
maybe it's a little harder today you
know over the last month
but you can still find people with money
who are on that who want to
enable your mission and can be mentors
not always not all of them but some of
them can be mentors but they they're on
your side
then it's incredibly powerful because
not just one plus one equals two right
it's something bigger than that because
then they can bring their networks of
people and their networks of companies
and other people they worked with that
might want to join your your your
mission right
that's the kind of venture capitalist
and and smart money that's out there
right but you have to build a
relationship people go oh look at that
valuation oh it's the brand name of the
vc that uh that's investing me no
it boils down to who's that partner and
how experienced are they don't just give
me the brand give me the person because
that's the person i'm going to be
interacting with
you